I wanna show you the trick that I Learned for poached eggs.
Okay, so the trick is,
I have water, half water,
half white vinegar in this bowl.
And then I cracked my eggs directly into this bowl
and let them sit for 10 minutes.
And you can see that they're kind of turning a little opaque color.
So when they start to turn this color,
you know that they are ready for your water.
Get our ladle, and we're going to carefully get the egg yolk
and egg whites into the ladle.
See that the egg whites are staying around the egg yolk.
Just get it out of the water,
and you have a perfectly poached egg.
Tiny bit of salt, little bit of pepper.
We got some sourdough bread,
and you have a perfectly poached egg.
Where's the yogurt? Like,
yogurt thing? Hmm.
Spicy. I have it.